Our two lines intersect at this point. We follow that up to the x-axis, looks to
be halfway between these two grid lines, which are x equals negative 4 and x
equals negative 6, which means, the x-coordinate is negative 5. The
y-coordinate, if we go over the y-axis, is negative 11. So, this point is
negative 5, negative 11. And the x-coordinate of that is negative 5. So, x
equals negative 5. Remember that the original equation we started with was 3x
plus 4 equals 2x minus 1. Let's make sure that negative 5 actually is a solution
for this equation. If we plug in negative 5 to the left-hand side, we get 3
times negative 5 plus 4. And this simplifies to negative 11, which was, in fact,
the y-coordinate that we found for our point. On the right-hand side, we have 2
times negative 5 minus 1, and that also equals negative 11. So, the solution for
x works for our original equation. Awesome.